♪.
JESSE: WELCOME TO "WATTERS
WORLD", I'M JESSE WATTERS.
THE MEDIA IS GETTING NERVOUS
AND THAT IS THE SUBJECT OF
WATER'S WORD.
THE DEMOCRATIC DEBATE WAS
AWFUL.
A BUNCH OF BORING LOSERS WITH
BAD IDEAS.
I HAD TO WATCH BECAUSE I GET
PAID TO.
AND HERE'S WHAT I LEARNED.
DEMOCRATS WANT TO BRIBE
TERRORIST, NOT KILL THEM.
WHENEVER THERE IS A THREAT TO
AMERICA, THEIR ONLY ANSWER IS
TO QUOTE BRING PEOPLE
TOGETHER.
WHATEVER THAT MEANS.
THEY KNOW NOTHING ABOUT
TRADE.
THEY SAY TRUMP IS BAD ON
TRADE, BUT THEN THEY VOTE FOR
HIS TRADE DEALS.
PROFITS ARE BAD, EXCEPT WHEN
DONORS GIVE THEIR PROFITS TO
THEM.
THEN THAT IS GOOD.
GASOLINE IS EVIL, WE ARE
GETTING GET RID OF GASOLINE
WHEN THEY ARE PRESIDENT.
I'M NOT SURE HOW I'M GET A
FILL UP MY TANK OR WHAT WITH?
THEY DON'T SAY THAT.
AND FINALLY WE NEED FREE
GOVERNMENT RUN DAYCARE.
LIKE ANYBODY ON THIS PAGE
WOULD GIVE THEIR NEWBORN TO A
GOVERNMENT WORKER FOR THE
DAY.
THE GOVERNMENT COULDN'T EVEN
GUARD JEFFREY EPSTEIN, THE
MOST IMPORTANT PERSON IN U.S.
CUSTODY.
A NUKES TRUST THEM TO KEEP
YOUR BABY?
WAIT UNTIL TRUMP FACES OFF
AGAINST THESE GUYS.
HE IS GOING TO CHOP THEM INTO
PIECES AND HE IS GOING TO
SMILE DOING IT.
HE IS EVEN COCKIER AND LOOSER
NOW THAN HE WAS WHEN HE
DEBATED CROOKED, AND HE HAS
WRAPPED UP A RECORD OF
ACCOMPLISHMENTS HE HAS A
TALKED ABOUT.
RECORD ECONOMY, BIGGER PAID
TRIBES, CHEAP GAS, ISIS BOMBED
AWAY, NO NEW WARS.
IT'S GOING TO BE A BLOODBATH.
FINALLY, THE DEMOCRATS IN THE
MEDIA ARE STARTING TO SEE IT.
>> I DIDN'T SEE ANYBODY ON THE
STAGE LAST NIGHT THAT COULD
REALLY SAID I AM GOING TO TAKE
CHARGE, I CAN BE PRESIDENT, I
CAN TAKE ON DONALD TRUMP.
>> THERE IS NOBODY ON THAT
STAGE TONIGHT THAT'S GOING TO
TAKE DONALD TRUMP OUT.
IF YOU ARE LOOKING AT THIS
THING YOU CAN SAY DID ANY OF
THESE PEOPLE PREPARE FOR WHAT
DONALD WILL DO TO THEM?
>> THEY WILL MARK THIS DAY,
JANUARY 13 AS THE DAY DONALD
TRUMP WAS REELECTED.
BECAUSE ONCE AGAIN, THE
DEMOCRAT COULD GET TOGETHER.
JESSE: WHEN THEY AGREE IT'S
TRUE.
BUT THE MEDIA HAS NOT TURNED
IN THE TILE YET.
THEY ARE GOING TO FIGHT TO THE
DEATH.
EVEN IF IT MEANS FIGHTING WITH
EACH OTHER.
AND CRACKS ARE STARTING TO
SHOW.
MSNBC IS NOW ATTACKING CNN.
>> IT'S ONE OF THE REASONS WHY
TRUMP KINO AND SHOULD WATCH
CNN BECAUSE MSNBC BECAUSE HE
KNOWS ON AN MSNBC THERE'S
GOING TO BE NO ONE DEFENDING
HIM BECAUSE WE DON'T PUT ON
LIARS.
I DON'T BRING ON LIARS.
I WON'T DO THAT.
AND THERE IS NO IT ON CNN.
>> YOU ARE GOING TO SAY TO
DEFEND TRUMP YOU HAVE TO LIE?
>> ABSOLUTELY.
HOW ELSE DO YOU DEFEND A
PATHOLOGICAL LIAR WHO LIES
ABOUT EVERYTHING.
SO CNN HAS PEOPLE ON THE
PAYROLL WHO THEY PAID TO TELL
THEIR LIES TO THE CNN
AUDIENCE, IN THE MIDDLE OF A
CNN HOUR FOR SOME NUMBER OF
MINUTES.
>> ALRIGHT SHOTS FIRED, THIS
IS RARE.
THESE CABLE CHANNELS DON'T
USUALLY GO AFTER EACH OTHER
LIKE THAT.
AND HERE'S WHAT IT TELLS YOU.
MSNBC IS GETTING DESPERATE.
THE PRIMETIME RATINGS OVER
THEY ARE DOWN BIG.
ESPECIALLY O'DONNELL'S.
BECAUSE THEIR AUDIENCE IS
DEPRESSED.
THEY HAVE BEEN LIED TO TOO
MANY TIMES.
NO COLLUSION, NO HIGH CRIMES,
THAT TAKES A TOLL ON YOU.
NOW CNN THEY'VE PICKED UP A
LITTLE BIT DURING
IMPEACHMENT.
AND YEAH, ONCE IN A WHILE THEY
WILL PUT A REPUBLICAN ON.
ONCE IN A WHILE THEY WILL HAVE
ONE GUY ON, OR ONE WHITE HOUSE
OFFICIAL ON DEFENDING TRUMP.
AND IN TRENT MSNBC CAN ACCEPT
THAT.
MSNBC CANNOT TOLERATE DEBATE,
THEY ARE INTOLERANT.
ANYTHING THEY DISAGREE WITH IS
ALIVE.
SO MSNBC WANTS INTERVIEW A
GUEST WHO BELIEVES TRUMP IS
DOING A GOOD JOB FOR AMERICA.
THEY SHUT DOWN CONSERVATIVES.
IF CABLE NEWS TO A
TOTALITARIANISM.
LIBERALS CAN'T DEBATE AND
SILENCE.
YOU SEE THAT IN SOCIAL MEDIA,
ON COLLEGE CAMPUSES, DOES
O'DONNELL SELLING 70 CONFIDENT
AS IDEAS KNOW HE SOUNDS SCARED
TO ME.
THAT'S WHAT'S HAPPENING.
THEY ARE RUNNING SCARED
BECAUSE TRUMP IS WITTING.
THEY HATE TO ADMIT IT, SOME
HAVE THE GUTS TO SAY IT LIKE
WHAT WE SHOWED YOU, OTHERS
LIKE LAWRENCE THEY JUST TRY TO
HIDE IT FROM THEIR AUDIENCE.
MSNBC DOES NOT PUT ON LIARS?
THEIR OWN ANCHORS LIED ABOUT
COLLUSION FOR THREE YEARS.
OR HOW ABOUT THIS, LAWRENCE
WAS PRACTICALLY GIDDY ABOUT
HOSTING THIS LIAR.
>> SITTING BESIDE ME RIGHT
NOW, I'M NOT LIKE SHE LEFT A
GUEST, A HINT'S NAME IS
MICHAEL AVENATTI.
>> NOW THAT LIAR IS BEHIND
BARS TODAY.
HE LIED ABOUT KAVANAUGH, YANG
RAKING PEOPLE, HE LIED TO
INVESTORS, CREDITORS, HE STOLE
CLIENT SPIRIT IS BANKRUPT.
BUSTED FOR EXTORTION.
MSNBC IS SO GULLIBLE THEY ARE
FILLED WITH SO MUCH RAGE, THEY
JUST GET PLAYED.
NOW MSNBC IS TROTTING OUT
ANOTHER LIAR, FACING HARD
TIMES.
AND GUY NAMED LEV PARNAS OR
WHATEVER, HE IS SUPPOSED TO BE
THE NEXT SILVER BULLET TO TAKE
OUT TRUMP.
REMEMBER FULL OF BOMBSHELLS,
BOMBSHELL AFTER BOMBSHELL,
THIS GUYS CHANGED HIS STORY A
DOZEN TIMES.
TURNS OUT HE'S NEVER EVEN TALK
TO TRUMP ABOUT UKRAINE.
NEVER.
EVEN CNN HAD TO CALL BS ON
MSNBC.
>> WE CAN'T IGNORE, PARNAS HAS
A VERY SERIOUS CREDIBILITY
PROBLEM.
HE'S UKRAINE'S SAID HE DOESN'T
TRUST A WORD PARNAS IS SAYING
ANYTHING PEOPLE OUT THERE IN
SOCIAL MEDIA, THE DEMOCRATS
ARE ACTING AS HE'S THE SECOND
COMING OF ROOSEVELT OR
SOMETHING.
JESSE: MORE SHOOTING INSIDE
THE LIBERAL TENTS.